so you can stay on the technical for
many years
so you offer them something they take it
and take it so what we'll do is we'll do
shanuchi
where i initiate take it
i take it
but just a little bit so i'm not just
doing shinuchi
totally gosh because if i do show
you come on if you push me
then the distance will be wrong if i go
in and make the distance i need
so i'm going to make the distance i need
but i'm here i'm winning i'm the one
doing this technique
it doesn't work if i play lingard
see what joy you get i'm having to force
myself
to find the connection if i'm too tired
to do that
please help
i'm going to be too deep if i go with
this
it's going to go past me i can adjust it
there
i'm actually gonna
i've got weight on the back leg i can't
adjust it
don't be too late if i try and adjust it
when it gets lighter
because i'm going this way i'm going to
adjust it
with my belly
work out the distance
the leg takes the body
it makes the tumor weight on it
push this back
i want you to find out where your over
commitment is sometimes even as they
come to you
the back leg
we are putting them together